i never teach kodagash from katadori
because
there's
hands together
one
because it's not basic because i don't
have one hand on him
two
i don't have my hand on him
three i don't have my hand on him
so they're the three coat of guy she's
that i would teach and that's what we're
going to do today to start off with
because the coat of gosh is this you
open your foot you turn your hand
you catch the inside of his thumb
you do that and you cut down
you bring over here
and you switch from there
we're going to all do this first
because i want to show you how useless
it is
you're in a straight situation just a
minute
i'll move my foot sorry i weren't
supposed to move my foot that's the
second stage you move your foot and you
cut it down
that's the second stage
the first state is you turn the hand
i'm having a job getting around there
look at my shape
you can hit me you know there's so many
things wrong with this technique but
because they scientist says you have to
show a basic coat the garage
this is the basic
that's what you're gonna do